welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of
everything you might have missed in the
moon night trailer featuring oscar isaac
as marvel's latest superhero coming to
disney plus and showing us how dark the
dark side that the man can get i was
changing my accent in the middle of the
sentence there didn't really work out
but i'm plowing through this because
unlike most mcu titles i break down
there actually are hidden demons in this
footage so i'm gonna go through it frame
by frame for all the terrifying details
you might have missed thanks to truebill
for sponsoring today's video more on
them in a little bit let's get started
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams we open on oscar isaac as
mark spector in the comics the son of a
rabbi who trains as a boxer and becomes
a badass cia agent a us marine and a
mercenary who gets possessed by the
egyptian moon deity khonshu who gives
mark powers associated with the cycle of
the moon and then as a moonlighting
vigilante he takes on alternate
identities that of wealthy elite steven
grant and taxi driver jake locklear then
in more recent comics his condition is
framed as a form of dissociative
identity disorder making mark and the
reader question how much of his
superpowers are actually in his mind and
that is a version of the character
explored in this series because here
mark is in a museum exhibit of ancient
egyptian artifacts on the right side of
the display case behind him there's an
artifact depicting three figures which
look like the egyptian sun god raw
falcon head god of fertility in the
afterlife osiris that's the pharaoh head
and his son anubis that's the canine
head guardian of the afterlife and
osiris is a character associated with
the practice of mummification and it
looks like raw and anubis may be doing
that to him here on the far left there's
a darker statue showing a figure with a
bull or maybe a bovine head could be set
or hepoo but on the right there's a
golden idol depicting a pharaoh and in
the foreground of all this is a
crocodile perhaps a display version of
the ones found in the nile river you can
actually see it better in the reflection
of that display case behind them but
weird things begin going on when you
focus on those reflections because first
off beneath that crocodile in the
reflection appears to be mummified
remains on the floor why would a mommy
be on the floor you're just gonna leave
it there not even use a coaster unless
this mummy was moved here because its
remains were disturbed and as mark exits
frame right his two reflections do not
follow him their heads actually turn
even someone independently of each other
just a way of reflecting mark's
splintered identities and as he exits a
bulky shadow that was once behind where
he was standing in the reflection
vanishes as he crosses it to leave frame
so what was standing behind him there
yeah folks it looks like mark's exposure
to and perhaps possession by the
egyptian moon deity of konchu must have
happened when he was meddling with these
artifacts maybe trying to steal one that
left him cursed hunting him wherever he
goes now then mark absorbs himself in a
mirror and there's a big lump on his
cheek perhaps from some vigilante brawl
when one of his other identities was in
control this guy's gonna find weird
bruises and scars all over his body that
he doesn't have a story for and then
from the end of a long dark room
elevator doors close on mark but this
time he's wearing uh some neater clothes
a black turtleneck this as we hear oscar
isaac speaking in a soft pitch british
accent i can't tell the difference
between my waking life and my dreams and
mark braces his hands against a bus
wearing these smooth white gloves which
when you compare with his suited white
fighting gloves later in the reel this
must be part of a different get up
entirely perhaps the cleaner white fancy
suit that he toggles into in the comics
then the creepiest shot in the trailer
mark lies in anguish in front of the
statue looks like he's hiding stifling
his screams hiding from what though well
if you look closely in the shadows
behind him some bulky shadowy figure
stirs can even see that it's arm is
creepily thin and two glowing eye holes
peering out at us
this could be kanchu creeping up on mark
here trying to take hold of his body and
possess him like in one division moon
knight seems to be steering hard into
supernatural horror specifically the
psychological horror trapping
protagonists in hells that have them
constantly questioning their realities
then mark is in a storage corridor
looking suspicious like someone's
sneaking around trying to steal an
artifact as opposed to the confident
badass mark begins as in the comics the
lights flash all creepy like because
demon's on the loose look i'm happy to
help you with all this stuff but the
real question is do you need someone to
grab the steering wheel of your
financial situation and keep you from
swerving all over the road like you're
playing a racing video game for the
first time and you don't understand the
controls well true bill take the wheel
truebill is the all-in-one personal
finance app that empowers you to take
back control of your financial life
helping you to save more and spend less
from a single dashboard truebill can
track all of your subscriptions in one
place cancel unwanted ones for you
negotiate bills on your behalf monitor
your credit score and automate your
savings i really like how easy truebill
makes it to set budgets and monitor your
spending you can visualize how much you
spend on different categories and then
set up a smart savings account so you
can finally start building up a nest egg
truebill uses the same security protocol
that banks use to ensure your personal
information is fully encrypted and true
build does not store your online banking
credentials or sell your information to
anyone get started with true build today
by heading to truebill.com
rockstars or clicking the link in the
video description that's truebuild.com
rockstars moving on the voice
in your head
it devours you
now here oscar isaac's voice shifts into
a lower raspier register as if he's
having a conversation with his alternate
self i'm so excited to see oscar isaac
play all these different incarnations of
his identities i'm wondering if the
english accent could be his steven grant
persona or even since it was a little
more uh cockney brits am i getting the
right one or is it yorkshire i regret
not knowing for sure either way it
sounds a bit more rough around the edges
making me think this could be a london
cabbie jake lockley whereas this lower
register seems to be the voice of the
moon night vigilante as the camera
rounds the corner there is a poster for
ancient egypt showing some artifact
perhaps this is how mark learned that
artifact was in the museum to begin with
and then we enter the bathroom
completely wrecked sinks mirrors smash
as this caped moon knight beats the hell
out of someone love the lighting here
the only visible light source in frame
is this daily fluorescent bulb smartly
positioned right beside moon knight so
that only he is illuminated the paleness
of his gray suit glowing like the moon
in the night sky now we cannot see who
he is beating up but as he stands his
cape straightens and shows well looks
like no one on the floor on the other
side of him so here's my hot take moon
knight is not beating up another person
but rather is beating the hell out of
himself fight club style as his
vigilante persona had to beat down one
of his other personas to take the wheel
this could be why the mirrors in
particular were smashed this all began
with mark seeing his own reflection more
amazing lunar imagery as mark runs
across a bridge with the bright bright
crescent moon reflecting on the water
i'm gonna guess this is the thames
because as he leaps across the building
to the other shot crossing the moon like
aat those buildings and tavern in the
lower left that's unmistakably london
architecture also that red bus he pushed
probably a classic london double decker
so rather than mostly being set in new
york like in the comics moon night here
might go down in the city of london
which would be interesting considering
the timing of eternals with cersei and
dane whitman working at the museum of
natural history in london which would be
one of the museums along with the
british museum that mark spector would
probably be in here now spoiler warning
for the eternal's post-credits scene but
this film ends with dane tracking down
his ancestral sword the ebony blade from
the property of his uncle nathan garrett
who is the previous black knight as the
voice of mahershala ali blade calls out
to him now we have speculated that these
two could end up on a supernatural
fighting force like the midnight suns
with warriors like moon knight as well
as potentially ghost rider someday if
marvel ever lets mafisto out of the cage
so now with mark spector as this horror
figure in the same city snooping around
the same kind of museums dane would be
in dealing with similar cursed artifacts
and hearing voices guys it's only a
matter of time before these nights cross
paths now other quick shots later show
moon knight in his official suit but not
his full form just his lower half and
then mark coming back into consciousness
after his alter ego beat up a ton of
people his fist bloodied up a mother
covering her girl's eyes i'm just so
excited to see this series suddenly
shift tone like this the way wanda
vision went in and out of stylistic
visual filters almost like what it would
be if we were to wake up from darkness
with bruce banner returning to his human
form confused as everyone around him ran
away screaming what a nightmare and what
an awesome nightmare this show is gonna
be so moon night's gonna be six episodes
on disney plus hopefully sometime early
2022 with ethan hawk playing an unknown
role that he described as a david koresh
type figure also gaspard yulio playing
anton mogart aka the villain midnight
man to support this channel check out
all one of our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow me
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis and breakdowns of
everything you love from the marvel
cinematic universe thank you for
watching bye
[Music]
[Music]
you